okay so the thor love and thunder
trailer ends with an electrifying shot
of jane foster wielding malnier looks
like she's come a long way since we last
saw her and she's now bringing that
hammer time that makes you feel like you
can't lift this
[Music]
you can't lift this natalie portman
coming on stage at comic-con to lift
malnia was a big talking point when the
movie was first announced and if you're
scratching your head over how this could
happen then here's the video for you
throughout it we're going to be breaking
down the story of mighty thor from the
comics and also discussing how mania
could be fixed i'm giving you a spoiler
warning right now so if you don't want
anything ruined then bye bye frost and
get the hell out of here please hit the
thumbs up button because fate wills
itself and make sure you smash subscribe
if you think we're worthy without the
way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into our jane foster breakdown
[Music]
okay so little is known about the mcu's
version of the character in terms of
where she comes from however if we look
at the comics we can start to piece
together her backstory and how she
potentially got to this point in the
source material jane's mother died of
cancer when she was very young and
though her father was there for the
majority of her childhood he sadly
passed away from a heart attack after
this jane put her full focus on science
and this led her on a fateful journey
first appearing in thor she quickly
became a loving trust for the character
and come the dark world she fused with
the aether a powerful infinity stone
with the capabilities of bending reality
up until that point she'd been a bit of
a plain jane and after the marvel movies
became a pain it didn't seem like we'd
see her again thank you natalie portman
had been burned in the past with big
franchises and when she didn't appear in
ragnarok everyone just assumed she'd
been burned out like anakin however
marvel brought her back in avengers end
game using deleted scenes and when
natalie appeared at the premiere it
seemed like something was afoot now in
the comics we saw a similar arc to what
we've had in the mcu so far though left
earth much like how he did in ragnarok
whereas there he was fighting cedar in
the comics he was fighting gore in the
film he'd be played by christian bale
who design is causing a bit of
controversy because of how much it
strikes from the comics
smooth
white slight impressions around the eye
very nice let's see paul allen's go
ahead i don't know don't know what came
over me there now this is all important
to bear in mind as though has to be off
world in order to tie into what happens
in the comics much like her mother jane
was diagnosed with breast cancer and
this could have potentially happened
during the events of ragnarok in the
five years between the snap in the blip
this may have developed further and
according to pubmed untreated breast
cancer can take about two to three years
to kill someone so if she was receiving
treatment during this time it may have
given her a couple of extra years in
between to bring us up to current day i
know breast cancer is a very serious
thing as well and i've had relatives
dive it so i don't want to be making
light of the disease just to talk about
comic book stuff but with there being a
five year time gap i thought i'd touch
upon how they may handle it in the story
and i don't mean to offend anyone now it
has to be said that jane was pretty much
a death star in the comics and though
she was offered magical treatment on
asgard she decided to decline it however
she did take chemotherapy but issues
rose from this when she gained those
powers which we'll talk about in just a
bit when fighting against nick fury
though ended up losing his ability to
wield mania and he became known as the
unworthy thor because no one else could
lift it it remained in place on the moon
and due to its sentience it started to
think for itself about who could be next
now this could somewhat tie in with
where the hammer was last left in the
mcu in the trailer we can see that it's
clearly being pieced back together as
there are cracks all over it and
therefore it seems like it's the one
hella smashed and not the one from end
game which cap of course returned due to
mulliner being something that you have
to be worthy to lift i think the pieces
of it might have remained outside
tonesburg at the site where odin died
and heller emerged the hammer might have
called out to jane and then using
hashtag signs she could have pieced it
back together potentially she might have
had help from e3 the dwarf who forged
stormbreaker in avengers infinity war
and it's going to be interesting to see
how they explain it now as we saw with
cap and endgame if you're wielding it
then you have the power of thor when
jane picked it up she gained all of his
abilities including super strength the
power to summon lightning and natalie
paul man you've got some big arms now i
can pretty much see this being what
happens in the movie and much like she
arrives on the scene during a battle in
the trailer something similar happened
in the comics she got caught up in a big
fight with malacath who wanted to
resurrect laffy but here it seems like
they're just jumping in with gore in the
background of the scene you can see what
appears to be the black berserkers of
gore but hey fan theories below now in
becoming thought jane ran into a lot of
issues with her chemotherapy upon
gaining the power of the god of thunder
everything from her body was purified
and put into a state of solidarity
because the hammer removed everything
toxic from her it also removed the
chemotherapy drugs as well however as
the cancer was part of her before she
lifted mollier it was seen as being
something within her that had to be
protected and thus it developed further
and got worse and worse still she
powered on and took part in arcs such as
secret wars secret empire all new all
different avengers and a lot more there
are some really great titles in there
and she became a fan favorite because of
them however as the cancer progressed
she got weaker and weaker and eventually
her mates convinced her to put the
hammer down you want me to put the
hammer down
however when asgardia started flying
towards the sun in a genocidal attack by
mangog natalie port mann got the hammer
one last time in order to put a stop to
him the beast put up one hell of a fight
and it was only when she tied it to
maligner and threw it into the sun that
she was able to finally vanquish the
beast however this pretty much destroyed
the hammer too and along with it came
thor's abilities she ended up
transforming back into her normal body
and this is when the cancer took its
toll and finally killed her but it
wasn't over yet now after meeting her
and seeing that she was worthy though
decided to allow her to take up the
mantle and he became known as odinson
just putting that in there as a
disclaimer so it doesn't get confusing
when i keep saying though all the time
he was crushed by her death but he
refused to accept it and after
channeling the god tempest he called
jane's soul back to the land of the
living in the afterlife she'd still at
the gates of valhalla however she
refused to go in and instead returned
back to mid-god she told odinson to try
all that he could to become worthy once
more and decided to focus on her cancer
treatment having been given the second
chance at life jane would beat the
cancer and she would once more end up
taking up arms with the asgardians which
led to her becoming a valkyrie with this
comes the power of flight enhanced sight
and also the ability to sense when death
is close by i think that the movie might
end up with her doing this whilst magnet
is given back to thor and it means that
we can kind of get the best of both
worlds where chris hemsworth still
remains in the role but we also get jane
foster's thor in the film lots of things
to look forward to in the movie and
though we're getting the usual get woko
bro commentary around the character in
the comic she goes on such a great arc
that i think it'll be brilliant if they
manage to adapt it properly for the mcu
we're kind of living in a time as well
where marvel are making different
versions of characters and we've of
course had all the loki's three
different spider-man and multiverse of
madness is going to have several
versions of doctor strange feels like
the next step for marvel is to bring in
alternate versions of established names
and you actually don't get much bigger
than jane foster natalie portman has
also been there since phase one so i
think it's going to be a great arc to
take her on that builds on a character
that got brushed to the side after thor
the dark world i can't wait to see what
tycoon does with her and in the meantime
i'd love to hear your thoughts on what
you want to see from jane in the film
comment below and let me know and just
to let you know we're running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of spider-man noway home on
the 15th of may all you have to do to be
on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the trailer
we picked the comments at random and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now serve that to you then message
me on twitter at heavyspoilers if you
want something else to watch then make
sure you check out all our theories
after the trailer which will be linked
on screen
right here right now if not then thanks
for sending through the video i've been
poor let's see in the next one take care
peace